have a good time up to the sky we got a
sparkle I'm counting down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking gonna have
a good time hands up to the sky we gonna
get roasted
[Music]
morning Lani Al's welcome back to the
morning toast happy Monday we hope
everyone had a very toasty weekend
whether you were partying with me in
Atlantic City or Kansas City or just at
home being a degenerate I'm happy for
you just like oh yeah but I wasn't a
degenerate because I was dog sitting my
favorite and a few CHS we had such an
incredible weekend it was like a great
weekend for me because obviously I got
relaxed but I was also so productive
took my new eyebrows out for a spin what
are we thinking guys can we get a
close-up jackie has she live in who
spoke about this on the podcast was it a
patreon no it was just a podcast episode
on Friday which by the way if you hadn't
have a chance to listen to yet it was
just the regular episode it went up late
but it was really good it was kind of
controversial I think so too but I think
we were just saying what a lot of people
are thinking yeah and we'll talk about
which people love to do more of the
Harry and Megan debacle on today's
episode because it's a never-ending saga
of confusion we spoke about it at length
on Friday's episode as well and Jackie
was coming out swinging with some really
unpopular opinions I don't think they're
unpopular that they're like unpopular if
you watch I don't know a lot of new
shows but if you talk with your friends
like yeah that's what you're saying no
they're unpopular in the sense that like
I feel like people are afraid to call
Megan Markel out for being a thirst
Megan man Harry Megan and Harry totally
yes oh my god sorry thank you for the
important yeah because like they don't
want to like feel like they're
contributing to like her Princess Diana
moment you know cuz yeah people just
don't want to be negative but that's the
price of being a celebrity like they're
negative about everything I'm sorry and
this is something I have a lot of
feelings about especially ever since the
video has been relocated we're jumping
ahead like we have such much to discuss
but stories yeah so we will get there um
but just want to catch up a weekend was
great
I was with the oh we had such a great
time we watch a couple American Ashley
movies and it was just a premium
experience loves national yeah he was
like really you living in his glory days
he's definitely more of like a Mary Kay
than an Ashley I would say because he's
a free spirit for sure for sure I just
really couldn't like into human
connection you know um
while I was watching the Mary Jane
ashley movies I was just enjoying myself
immensely they said while swatching
whilst watching watching American
national movies I was enjoying myself
immensely like and I realize how
important
were in our childhood like as they were
in that was like the era before Hannah
Montana so they were really like our
number ones and I really think they
contributed to like these sisterly
steamy vibes that we have going on today
hold like all of their movies are about
the importance of family of family and
sisterhood and then also like style and
romance and it's just like a wonderful
amalgam of themes
yes sisterhood style and romance for
sure we know for sure with an emphasis
on all three equally and what's cool
about those movies is that I remember
watching them at different ages which
means that we were different ages like
they were really young and some movies
and in New York min it was like they're
more mature and now one actually hit
theaters that was the last one we got
and boy like we were so unworthy Simple
Plan performed in the movie set it's
such a good movie it's on Netflix right
now and you have to watch it I know well
I watched um I caught up on marvelous
mrs. hazel this whole weekend and Ben
got really really into it this isn't an
ad even though we do do reads video you
should walk because it's really good but
like I could not believe the decision
that she just made like I'm so upset
with midge and like I really don't
relate to her as a character and she's
one of those Carrie Bradshaw types where
you don't agree with the protagonist a
lot and she just made literally the
Thomas decision of her life and like I'm
done with her like I'm done are you done
with the show no I saw more episodes and
I'm like really like aunt but I just I
had a I had thoughts but I don't want to
finish it until I finish and I know you
don't watch them
oh yeah finish it also I watched here on
Netflix which will recap at the end oh
my god cheer on Netflix like so many
I've changed I think the hardest part
about watching share on Netflix is
wanting to stock them all on Instagram
but not wanting Daytona to be spoiled
for yourself okay so I'm not gonna lie
well I looked up in the middle of the
series like on Twitter it was just like
fact-checking something and I saw that
they spoiler alert Joe I saw what
happened at Daytona and like I literally
want to choke myself like I was so upset
at myself when I was watching Daytona I
literally had a pit in my stomach like
just from the suspense of it all and
varsity chairs having to really like the
scientology of national associations
like them not letting them film them he
had like janky iphone footage yeah it
was it was wild out here you guys we're
gonna recap cheer I guess like we just
should move on to the things that we're
actually gonna talk about right now
instead of talking about the things that
we're going to talk about back to
mary-kate nationally totally agree on
that being such influential influences
in our lives
and after New York minute Zach and I
watched passport to Paris and that movie
just slaps it ages so well when they're
in church rise the jokes are still so
funny and then last night I watched our
lips are sealed and I guess that was it
was a letdown because I had to spend $15
on it so I needed it to be incredible
whereas passport to powers is on Hulu oh
is it yep um and I just like I wonder
what's next for me I think now that I'm
thinking about it I when you said
passport to Paris was like oh that's
definitely my favorite but then I think
of our lips are sealed when they're in
the witness protection program and I
think that one might actually be my
favorite like when they're on the yacht
and those super cute like go-go dresses
I use well no you know like passports
Paris is better what about I'm switching
teams oh that's a great one but they're
they're just really young and like it's
a different type of movie it's a much
different type of movie like what am i
doing spending my Saturday night
watching kicking in sorry children like
what are you yeah no not sure yes
positive posit so I just think I know
it's early but I do think in the words
of my namesake on the Lion King
commercial it is time I do think it is
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast yeah no
I I don't I don't necessarily disagree
and you know me I love to disagree but
I'm just really excited and I do have to
cut you off again because I have to let
everyone know about our newest sponsor
which we did our first read for on
Friday and they disappear and the Jackie
and I are literally obsessed with and I
can't believe that they are not
sponsoring our show the real real if you
want to own iconic luxury items at an
unreal value with the real real it is
the leading seller of authenticated
luxury consignment from top designers
like Louis Vuitton Gucci rolex cartier
and hundreds more and it's all up to 90%
off retail
you can shop and consign women's and
men's luxury fashion and street wear as
well as jewelry watches art and home so
Jackie and I both shop at the real real
like I shop till we drop
clothing mostly bags and accessories and
I also get stuff for been there and it's
just like I love to like live like a
queen but not like spend like one you
know anything I'm in the real world has
been great for that and then especially
with Jackie which we spoke about her
shopping problem last week when it's
time to clear out and make space for new
stuff we also both sell on the reel reel
so it's great to feel like you're
investing in stuff and then if you don't
end up wearing it are you just like have
your time has run out with
yeah it's great to just feel like you're
getting that money back and freeing up
space in your closet and since it's
technically thrift shopping you're
you're doing well for the environment
it's just very sustainable shopping you
are and since I am an investor in
fashion or so you're gonna say an
investor in the real real I'm like look
at you and we have a [ __ ] wish you
know I'm an investor as we spoke about
last week I'm a collector collector and
the real real has like the best vintage
items one-of-a-kind pieces like never to
be seen before ever again throw it up
put it in a blender give birth to it ago
it's just it's lit the reel reel has new
arrivals that come in daily and every
item undergoes the wheel rails
meticulous authentication process in
fact the real real employees over a
hundred brand specialist gemologist
horologist and art curators from around
the globe who would inspect thousands of
items each day to ensure that every item
is authenticated you can shop luxury the
sustainable way go online or download
the app or you can now visit one of
their stores in Soho or West Hollywood
and they have a brand new location in
the city at 870 Madison Avenue oh sorry
I'm dying over here and if you want to
consign you can check out their White
Glove service for free in home pickups
you don't have to ship a big box they'll
come over take your stuff get it out of
your way it's really great shop in store
online or download the app and get 20%
off select items with the promo code
real just like Simon van Kempen I am
real re al that's the real real calm
promo code real for 20% off select items
I absolutely love shopping on the app
and I just recommend it highly highly
recommend it like it's a great way to
shop because you got great things for
great prices and you're also doing well
for the environment with each item that
you buy they let you know how much water
you saved and how much you're helping
this planet so sign on have a cute [ __ ]
umm Before we jump in I did want to
recap because I went out on Friday night
to an art show which was like really not
like me I don't think I've ever really
been to an art show and it was very
elevated experience but I ran into the
lady sitter who I just want to say is
one of the funniest people I've ever had
in my life and I was really trying to
convince him to do stand-up because he's
so funny
um I just think he like loves his life
at me and I'm like I'm not telling him
to move him just like just try it and
it's very scary like to tell someone to
try but we were just talking he said
something like an offhand remark that he
was like I think a comedian would spent
years coming up with something so funny
we were just talking about someone who
wore like
bad wig like a celebrity and someone at
the table who like wasn't really in wig
well versed and celebrity like life was
like well why was the person wearing a
wig like what's their hair like and we
me and Jessa more like well they don't
really have a lot of hair I said I'm
like the person I was like three strands
of paper Justin goes she's like no hair
I could blow dry it with my mouth
you told Larry shobe and I just love
spending time with him and he's foj in
front of the toast and I just loved him
yeah and I was like taking hot takes him
I'm like what do you think about what's
going on here
anything interesting like chef ass no he
did tell me who he ran into Morgan
Stewart on a date with thank God and
Claudia told me and now my life's
complete and like I just want to be like
thirsty and like exploited it but like
weirdly
I've never known that it was a each
other yes okay so I didn't feel like
there's so much stuff out there that we
don't know like yeah no I didn't feel
out of the you know what is a great
update to share with the class today is
that the morning toasters Facebook group
is now open for membership open
enrollment over there we have wiped
clean all the requests so if your
request was pending you've been declined
which is good news for you because it
means we're starting fresh we're letting
people in make sure your answers are
pertinent to the situation I can't
stress this enough you make sure like
you know overdo it instead of under do
it legs insane like we had to we had to
release all there was like 20,000
requests and as much as we wanted to let
everyone in there's like snitches and
just it's like a year's worth of
snitcher ii and and we don't want to
ruin like the vibe of the group right
now is so positive but we know there are
so many more people who listen to the
podcasts that aren't in the group and
any time I like meet someone or even
open a DM it's like the somebody's
having also PS like let me into the
group so we want everyone to be in the
group who wants to be in the group
without sacrificing the by but that
means snitches so if it's something that
is important to you apply write
thoughtful answers let us let us think
that you at least watch the show you
know let us know that you watch the show
and your life will be changed for it so
head on over there here if you're
listening to this say right A to E oh
yeah yeah that's great so I know but
then like what I'm posting I'm ready
they said ratatouille
okay first story I figured we would just
start with the big news of the day that
isn't Mexico
because they just wanna you know and
also like I'm starting to get China by
it's like no no are you kidding me today
is the magazine summit they're all
meeting a megan is conferencing in Oh
from Toronto from she in trauma or
Vancouver Toronto okay from Canada from
cup anyways first story Oscar
nominations are in and it's it's snub
season it's nob season people are really
upset at I'm Joey J Adam Sandler is
trending on Twitter okay it's not snips
I wasn't talking about I'm saying the
world
I was talking about frozen to I was
talking about Jamie on say and I was
talking about JLo Beyonce she nominated
for the song no shook yes Taylor Swift
no I'm sorry even though the Taylor
Swift song is good cats cannot be an
oscar-nominated movie then they'll put
it in the commercials and no one should
be duped into seeing I agree did you see
her no but buds acted okay so I feel
like I didn't okay the award for Motion
Picture nominations Ford vers Ferrari
which I want to see it can't you can't
tell if it's about presidents cars or
race car drivers cars maybe all three
race car drivers like it's about Gerald
Ford or Ford Motors Ford Motors it's a
lot of motors versus Ferrari motors yeah
it's like who made the bay the better
sport is hard and they I think they race
them so I think it's about cars and race
car drivers I I thought it was about to
race car track maybe it was a race car
drivers running for president one named
Gerald Ford
no and one named something Ferrari well
that would just be a weird quince what
it's about the motor companies go cool
the Irishman Jojo rabbit Joker little
women marriage story 1917 once upon a
time in Hollywood and parasites that's a
lot of movies yeah well because at the
Golden Globes they nominate buy movie
drama and moving comet comedy or musical
but now they just put them all together
got it well I was um
I was with a bunch of Ben's friends on
Saturday night we were talking about
like Oscar movies and some was talking
about Georgia rabbit which like I hadn't
even heard of and I was like has anyone
seen what's who framed roger rabbit like
as a joke and everyone's like no he
believed nobody has seen that movie
uncultured swine using our shirts right
except one person Luke she's like a film
buff he's seen and he likes agree that
it was a great movie but I just couldn't
believe that all these quote-unquote
like a movie goer like people who are
invested in film culture I have never
seen the greatest
of all time Who Framed Roger Rabbit
sickening okay Betty toasters have it
sickening
Best Actress nominee Cynthia areevo
Scarlett Johansson Schwarz a Ronan
Charlize Theron and Renee Zellweger
Saoirse Ronan I likes wash a best actor
Antonio Banderas Leonardo DiCaprio Adam
driver Joaquin Phoenix Jonathan Pryce
Joaquin Phoenix is gonna win I think I
mean I'm the Joker had the most
nominations and I do think that they'll
like I think it'll be the Slumdog
Millionaire I think there's a lot of
good choices in in that category actress
in a supporting role Kathy Bates
apparently that was um a surprise for
Richard Jewell which I'm still dying to
see there's so many movies and I'm dying
to see and I just can't get around to
that no I know I'm dying to see 19:17 I
need to become a member of the Academy
or something so that you can get the
movies they send like a DVD and you
could just watch it at home um remember
how we were talking about 1917 in the
cube speech that he made because like he
doesn't have any movie star record
breaking Bobby has been great weekend at
the box I'm so happy for them and start
up yeah you know like you just are you
really rooting for them they're like
entrepreneurs your take totally oh my
god I have to talk about Chuck tanked
last night okay Laura Dern's nominated
Scarlett Johansson for you chose your
rabbit who knew she was in that Florence
pug and margot robbie actor just like
movies like the marriage story and
irishman are really bothering me because
they're star-studded and they're not
good and they just get nominated because
I can't have a movie with all these
people and it not be nominated you like
the Irishman you know like think of the
disrespect of like all these people
getting together well I think that even
though the Irishman wasn't overall not
good
I think the acting was incredible I
think there were elements of it that
deserve nominations I do but it's
nominated for Best Picture um I
understand I understand that like I
don't know I just don't think any like
it was they didn't land the plane but I
had a nice time on the flight yeah but
you know I just don't think that because
a lot of people are in it it deserves to
be nominated like this is a senior I'm
not saying that it's nominated because a
lot of people aren't in I think the
people did a good job yeah fine so they
can get nominated
like the film is a whole being nominated
like I just think it's it's it's like a
mirage like you just think it's a good
way because there's so many good people
in it no I think if they were just
nominating for the sake of nominating
cats would be in the mix you literally
couldn't nominate cats like the you just
couldn't like the review like you it
would be it would be a joke if you
nominate the cats but I just think the
Irishman is like we didn't enjoy it a
lot of people didn't enjoy it but I
think cinematically it's a masterful in
way yeah but don't you think like a good
gage unlike the cinematical masterpiece
of a movie is whether or not people
liked it I know look at the lobster your
old friend the work brother made but it
was univer that's what I'm saying okay
that's a perfect example it was a
universally regarded as a [ __ ]
horrible movie and just because like
Keanu Reeves or whoever was in it it's
like oh this is so great and just
because it's like hard to understand it
and dense people think that means it's a
good movie like no movies should be easy
to understand this is an SH piece yeah
well you know what it won't winning and
I do think at a certain point like
Martin Scorsese puts out a body of work
with uh so and so and so and so we just
have gone back we have no choice but to
respect let's see
I don't agree the Oscars should be based
on merit I think that is merit merit a
lot of people's career of the movie I
think it's a very another Caprio never
getting nominated but he should have
gotten nominated he should have won a
million times just because of his merit
you know no I think he should have run a
million times like because of the work
that he did right and the revenant was
literally terrible but like catch me if
you can catch me behind which I just
watch for the fair that I'm Django
Titanic What's Eating Gilbert Grape
Oh Gilbert Grape a heartbreaker
heartbreaker of a film um Best Actor in
a supporting role Brad Pitt I hope he
wins I could so go for another speech Al
Pacino Joe Pesci Tom Hanks and Anthony
Hopkins
well that's like not wait what was that
category Best Actor in a supporting role
oh so so that's not the same as Joaquin
Phoenix oh no no that's main actor do
you think that Brad Pitt will win that
category it doesn't seem like real stiff
competition I I really hope so animated
feature film interesting because frozen
two got snubbed How to Train Your Dragon
I lost my body Klaus on Netflix Klaus I
don't know missing link and Toy Story 4
weird Zac actually watched Klaus and he
did not like it Ben saw choice 24 and
swore like it was the bed
movie ever made in the entire world also
The Lion King should have been nominated
in that category I believe and the
snobbery going around for the Lion King
Beyonce and Jon Favreau I give me my
gavel like it's it's it's a disgrace Jon
Favreau Jon Favreau yes sad bro problems
let's go okay I like love Jon Favreau
what is he what do I know him from um
couples retreat no before that
he was in chef that Netflix movie got
the food truck okay I'll google it um
but he liked his initial role is
something iconic and I always get him
confused with the dad from the Goldbergs
pretty sure the guy from Larry David
yeah yeah yeah because they look exactly
like I but I know that guy has like a
weird thing with his cheek and so that's
how I know that it's him he's also in
Entourage but Jon Favreau okay like he's
in a lot of stuff he's in for
Christmases is that what you're thinking
of he plays Vince Vaughn's brother no
keep going um like I don't know when
something's gotta give
who was he and something I don't know
but like all these movies are coming up
that he was in oh my god it's really
bothering me
I don't know swingers identity thief I
love you I love you man me I think it's
couples retreat that you can see here
I've had yeah sure
because he's just like a like a really
iconic figure like in my mind and I
don't know what from maybe like a TV
show I mean I remember the movie
windle's in yeah crazy move what a good
movie crazy me somethings i think it's
couples retreat you're thinking of
that's what it is for me I just can't
picture him he was in the break-up he
was Vince Vaughn's friend yeah he's
always Vince Vaughn's friend I had no
clue they had like an Adam Sandler
what's he in the wolf of wallstreet or
like directed cuz he's like a star but
that now he he now he's a big-time
director and he did the Lion King and he
knocked it out of the park he's an elf
maybe that's it or maybe he's I'm not
sure he's just a start of me you know
yeah but maybe it's because I keep
confusing him for the guy and then the
Goldbergs
feel like he'd get oh oh what isn't you
he's figure friends he's Pete Becker
right yes oh my god thank you that was
bothering me so much yes and also that
really reminds me that why Monica's the
worst because Pete was like the best guy
for her and like yes even he wants to
become the Ultimate Fighting champion he
was a billionaire he was basically like
Bill Gates he he he Majid moss 98 which
was like Microsoft he and
Monica was like just not into him cuz he
was like a little too reckless for her
like my god she's so judgmental like
relax and he gave her $10,000 tip at the
diner like that's how he knew and she'd
like thought she was so offended I'm
like [ __ ] take the money get around
like you're looking nowadays he would be
like go viral no in that tent doesn't
think of it like depreciation that's
$4,000 probably from in the last 20
years it's like 30 perhaps something
like that something like that um anyway
interesting thing about watching this is
amazing oh he said she's like my phone
bill is $47 she's like oh and have to
ask my dad for kind of money like that
let's like 47 dollars you know it's up
the money they do a good job of like
really like capturing the time
interesting very interesting I'm really
upset about the Lion King snobbery
because it was just a work of art I
think I'm done in an era where we're
getting movies like cats now we're
seeing you know it's not so easy to put
on an animated film in the animated
feature film in live-action 3d and they
think of all the movies I saw this year
Lion King was the one that impressed me
the most and I think the one that like
really got me in my feelings the most a
hundred percent and I think I'm upset
for Beyonce I'm upset for Jon Favreau
I'm upset for Jon Favreau I feel like
he's like a really hard worker I can't
explain it I'm like Loki he's just like
he's what's that quote where it's like -
he's just like working in the dark you
know he's not asking for anything it's
like people he's not tweeting about his
snub but no or like how hard he's
working like you know Instagram starting
you know in the studio 6:00 a.m. like no
but he just works hard keeps his head
down yeah totally I love him there's a
phrase and I'm not remembering it but I
know the phrase you're referring no it's
like what you do in the dark shows in
the light is that what you're thinking I
think it's from that Michael Phelps
commercial even though I did just hear
like a quote it's totally unrelated to
this conversation but I just heard like
a phrase that really spoke to me ready
okay I love a good phrase yeah ready
money talks but wealth whispers oh for
sure totally totally I thought you were
gonna be like but something walks no no
it's not a rhyme but it's just um just
one that really spoke to me made me want
to become wealthy I love that for you
that for you a Best Original Song which
is a category I always feel a kinship to
I can't let you throw yourself away from
Toy Story for I'm gonna love me again
from Rocket Man I'm standing with you
from breakthrough into the unknown
frozen - they should have nominated -
show yourself maybe they'd have stand a
chance and stand up
from Harriet Elton John is gonna win
yeah well I didn't even know that that
wasn't an original like song from Elton
John's career totally but it should be
sperrit by Beyonce yeah I think I'll
just keep going we're beautiful gross
but it's okay it just can't be
um actually saw a tweet today when I was
reading like people's reactions of the
the three pop stars who are half there
who are on their way to when he got
mm-hmm it's Lady Gaga Adele and Taylor
Swift because Taylor has the old Grammys
Taylor has an Emmy I don't know what
from and then Gaga and Adele both have
Oscars so we need one of them to star in
a Broadway I think of all them if
anyone's gonna get there first it's
gonna be Lady gaga
I think so too because she really is so
like perform like I could see you're
just randomly being nominated for a Tony
and she was nominated for an Emmy
American Horror Story yes so like she'll
just do something like that again yeah I
think like I think her doing American
Horror Story was her wanting to be Annie
got for sure yeah but she got the hard
ones down I think Grammy an Oscar the
hard ways heart but the ones that are
more in her wheelhouse and now she's
gonna have to go and spend time on
Broadway I'm down yeah we're good Wow
like she loves New York she does she
would enjoy has a place here okay now
let's get to the real meat potatoes meat
and potatoes the heart of the issue
where do we begin on the Royal news
that's happened since this weekend I'm
gonna start with the fact that Meghan
Merkel has reportedly signed a deal with
Disney following the Royal split then
yesterday a video was was making the
rounds of her and Harry at the Lion King
premiere in July while Meghan was
talking to Beyonce and jay-z Harry is
random iPhone literally caught the video
of a century like it's so weird that
this would be caught on tape uh Harry
was seen conversing with Bob Iger the
CEO of Disney front of the toast and
allegedly apparently if he read lips and
can hear well um he's asking for our job
for Megan he's saying that she does
voiceovers she does voiceovers right and
he was like oh no I didn't he didn't you
seems by the way why would anyone know
that first of all he almost feel like
seemed like he was offended that Bob
Iger didn't know that and then he's like
you seem surprised and I was like yeah
no I had no idea he was inking she would
really love to do something she's really
interested and I said we'd love to try
that's a great idea
like literally making business deals on
a red carpet and then I posted this on
the Instagram and I was really really
curious to what to see what people were
gonna say and it was a toast community
divided because half of the people were
on there
like oh my god goes like I wish someone
was my champion like that like oh my god
look he's hurting number one a fad and
then other people were just very blatant
being like damn this is one of the
thirstiest things I've ever seen in my
life like a prince almost like that
wasn't a casual conversation like when
you're a prince like you're basically
not demanding like it's you can't just
have a conversation like that now Bob
Iger whether or not he wanted to like he
had to give this deal to Megan because
the prince required it he was commanded
but I think what's even crazier is that
they were in no position to be getting
jobs or doing endorsements or anything
like this back in July so the wheels
have been in motion for their departure
departure for a long time but not long
enough for them to have a real
conversation with the Queen about it you
know about it in the right way so I did
a poll on my story mm-hm I really
because I feel like everyone is on two
sides of the fence I said let's just set
it straight like are we thinking that
Megan you know is thirsty and her and
Harry are breaking up the royal family
or is this all just like genuine and
like she really just wants to get away
from it all and like the the media is
misconstruing a lot of and it was a
country divided 48 percent time to put
the media's misconstruing anything at
least not the media here everyone here
is like you know this respectful
respectful he doesn't want Princess
Diana part - they just want quiet lives
and you know what like I think only time
and what they do next will tell what
what their intentions have been from the
start if they want to go live a quiet
life in Canada and like be
semi-anonymous and just you know they
can't deal with the press in the media
like I would completely completely
respect that and understand that because
that life is not for everyone
but if they moved to LA where they spend
their time in LA like they pay taxes in
Canada but are mostly in LA they're
going to the Met Ball they're you know
here they're there and they're doing
voiceover deals with Disney and there
are Netflix and this and that like it's
it's wrong and so then they're
essentially bigger stars than they would
have been if they were just you know
doing the Royal so they're not leaving
the Royal did they Diana pressure it's
probably worse here yeah like at least
in in Buckingham Palace there's an
element of like respect and protection
that you get just by being a royal not
in terms of what people can say about
you but just in terms of like your
physical place in the world so I think
that this is turning into more of what
we thought it was going to be when I
first heard the story and it's just it's
so weird and it's really what did you
think it was gonna be when you first
heard this story when I first heard the
story I was like oh thirsty wants to
live in LA and then it's like no they
want to spend more time on Philanthropy
and then for a second I really thought
that like this was really too much for
her and that she was gonna live in
Canada and live a quiet life and like
really just be like a full-time
philanthropist whatever that means
um but now it's just like with all the
news of like their businesses that
they're forming and like they own like
114 ip's and and Disney deal and I'm
sure more things will come out about
that now it's like a little confusing
and and it's coming off really
disrespectful disrespectful thirsty and
it's like they don't want to do the job
of you know opening up a community
center in South Wales cuz that's not
sexy and that's what people think being
a princess is like wearing fine jewels
the crown jewels and like going to a
party every night when it's not it's a
parent that's have to get to half the
job but it's it's hard work and it's
kind of boring and it's not super sexy
all the time and you don't really get to
be like famous and get like a lot of the
perks of what it means to be famous and
I think that that's what Megan wants and
then both of them it takes two to tango
you don't just leave your family or post
because your wife is like oh I want to
do a Disney voice Oh Bryce no I agree
it's both of that but I I think that
what you said about the timing of the
Lion King premiere is weird
beyond because that means this whole
thing was like really premeditated and
planned like well I think you have to
have a plan when you do something like
this I hope they had a plan but it just
means it like they first of all they
were out of they're not supposed to be
campaigning for jobs and movie deals
right while they're still Royals so they
were there like on a royal duty like
they were there representing the royal
family at an event like that's work for
them so it's just it's thirsty but it's
also like not Emoto it's improper yeah
um and it just shows that like they've
obviously had this in the works for a
while so why couldn't they go about it
the right way with the blessing of the
Queen because now today is the day of
the big mech sit conference where the
Queen is sitting down with Charles and
William and Harry and I guess Megan is
calling in I would just like love to get
the dial-in info for that I would just
absolutely love to be a fly on that wall
and what's so upsetting is like you get
so invested in other people's stories um
in other people's lives and then there's
like we'll never know what's being said
and everything we talk about here about
the royal family could be like total kin
sure like we'll never really know what's
going on that's like with Solange and
Beyonce and elevator like we'll never
really know what happened in the
elevator I mean we'll never really know
like what's being said between like what
the Queen truly feels you know unless
she makes a move after after she all the
dust settled and she takes their titles
away I was reading in the news this
morning a lot of a lot of Brits want oh
yeah I guess like right and then also
being the popular opinion as an American
it's like so different
I would love to we need like a British a
scone a British toast to let us know
what-what the British public feels cuz
we're not really affected by this we
just like look at it all from like a
salacious gossip point of view but like
it's important in Britain like and in
politics and in just like the culture so
I would love to know what the people of
Britain are saying yes I I would and I
think that will affect how how things
are handled that would be crazy if they
lost their title I don't know if it
would really affect like the there still
be just as famous here in America but
there's probably certain things they
can't do no end like those Mirchi vibes
and those trademarks gone oh my god so
sad though
the Daily Mail did like an in-depth pode
the Daily Mail is [ __ ] savage on the
person who runs their Instagram it's
like some just kid like an intern
basically and he misquoted like Maya
Angelou and there was like this whole
drama I mean they like put it like he's
just like a private citizen who was a
job you know any obviously has a high
profile job but the end of the day like
he's just a regular person and the hotel
email did like a whole thing on him oh
my god you also people are saying that
their Instagram account was started
around the time of the Lion King
premiere like over the summer and so
this this has all been you know this
orchestrate israfil yeah because it's
like you don't just go off on your own
until you're an influencer and you have
and you can be selling that bit fun yeah
I mean if the day ever comes whether
they were doing Instagram ads like I
will die I don't think it's gonna come
to that because I see them as like um
it's it's an interesting career one like
I don't even know who I could compare it
to where it's like you're a celebrity
but you're because we don't have
royalties royal not royalties Royals in
America so it's like a level of
celebrity that's kind of unchartered
where it's like you can do certain
things like I think they'll definitely
do like fashion campaigns I think like
Megan will be like on a fragrance ad you
know in every airport in America but for
like D or something but she's not gonna
be out here Hawking tea or doing a lot
of things that celebrities do like even
the Kardashians where American royalty
like there's so much they do I said
he's like they're not gonna make it's
not gonna be doing Club appearances you
know I would love that I go but she's on
a different planet she's like at the
same level as Oprah yes I would agree
with that but anyways it's I hope we
have more news tomorrow after after the
big comfort you should pick back up on
her blog after a Meg con what was it
called
t22 t uh the TIG the TIG the TIG Ziggy
I'm sorry we don't know sorry I'm the
TIG yeah that girl which is the TIG is
the I mean she really is that girl well
ya know she manifested that for her sass
believersí maybe she'll pick her blog
back up um I think she will become like
a lifestyle guru expert I love a guru
love a guru anyways it'll be interesting
for her I'm just I I'm excited to see
what comes of all this I like any year I
would love to watch this show and be
like what were we thinking you know cuz
we'll know it then what the plan was
yeah I just want to see where they where
they're spending most of their time
actually be even crazier if they like
move to Vancouver and then spend all
their time in LA because it's like oh
they're trying to pull the wool over our
eyes well I just read in pink chicks
which means could not be true that they
won't live in America Megan refuses
still in America until Trump's out of
office because her and him have beef oh
and she made a comment about him before
she was a royal and then he responded
when she was a royal so she couldn't say
anything because I think the Queen is I
totally completely which I also think
maybe part of the reason why Megan
wanted to leave because she's very
passionate about certain topics maybe
she wanted to get in on you know the
very touch-and-go political climate here
in America perhaps because she missed it
in Britain I can't imagine anyone
missing what's going on here but I would
love to move we will keep you posted you
guys at but I mean all you have to do is
open your eyes it's everywhere it's the
story you don't need us to get you the
story of a lifetime the thirst that is
Megan and Harry and you know maybe they
should get some liquid ID because
they're looking quite dehydrator oh
that's a great idea
everyone is talking about liquid IDs
hydration Multiplier you've even heard
how much we love it but have you heard
of their latest product and the liquid
IV energy multiplier their energy
multiplier tastes amazing just like
their eleven line flavour basically all
you got to do is mix in water and it
gives you a sustained energy boost with
absolutely no crash one of the things we
love most about like what IV is that
they're on a mission to change the world
so they've donated to millions
to date to places like Haiti Uganda
Puerto Rico and Nepal with each person
purchase you may click what Ivey donates
a serving to someone in need around the
world do good feel good what's not to
love their premium matcha and green
energy blend tastes delicious and
provides the lasting energy boost
throughout the day the fatigue fighting
boosts you'd get from a couple of cups
of coffee without the crash it contains
a mixture of teas and herbs high in
antioxidants that help improve mood and
focus I hope their alternative to
traditional energy drinks and coffee
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives
we love liquid ID great for a hangover
um if you want to get 25% off when you
go to the liquid IV com use the code
toast at checkout so that's liquid IV
dot-com the code is toast that's 25% off
anything you order on liquid IVs website
just go to liquid IV com enter the promo
code toast to save 25% and get better
hydration and energy liquid IV dot-com
promo code toast don't wait start
fueling your adventures today sign on
get hydrated great for a hangover
great first you're just not drinking
enough water and you just want like the
the liquid that you're drinking to to
double up on the hydration you know yeah
okay next up the most devastating news
that I've heard in a long time
which is that Jeffrey Starr and his
boyfriend Nate had indeed split after
five years together
Jeffrey posted a video to his YouTube
channel on Saturday morning caption we
broke up like confirming what none of us
wanted to believe what we actually here
at the toast refused to believe and I'm
so shocked the video is it's important
it's nice it's boring it doesn't really
tell us why they broke up who broke up
with who put the baby they have a chance
of getting back together the vibe that I
got and before if you had told me that
they would have broken up I would have
just pretty much assumed they would have
broken up with him because they think
nate is just like not really fit for
this life um and Jeffrey like was made
for it but the vibe that I got from the
video was that Jeffrey's like really
kind of doing okay and that he might
have been the one who doesn't who broke
up yeah it wasn't clear at all or maybe
it was mutual and maybe they had so much
coming on but they knew they both
weren't doing well and they when they
finally took the time to sit down and
talk about things they both had it on
their mind I don't know I'm just
speculating because I just need like
some logic I know because this makes
this is makes no sense to me like we
were just here like we just
oisin documentary I do filete you like I
to me Jeffrey and me were like what true
love what true love looks like
and just stability what stability looks
like gonna support and what support
looks I an industry that's like so crazy
like Jeffrey has well he always says
like so many highs and so many lows like
having that partner I feel like really
can help like sustain like your mental
health and I feel like Nate was like a
real rock for Jeffrey even though like I
obviously don't know them I just like
really feel like I do know them from
just being such a big fan um and it was
it was just really devastating and I do
feel like Jeffrey was speaking directly
to me when he said that people were
reporting that his mom died you know
what I like I saw it and I didn't think
he was talking about don't mean either
but so many people like to yeah I mean
like Jeffrey was talking about you
obviously by the way I never said on
this show I never reported it as fact
then his mother passed away I just felt
like people were freaking out about so
many things that were going on like him
canceling the tour so I just I was
looking for and it's like a scapegoat
like and I never reported I don't think
he was talking to me I don't think his
mom really there was ever anything wrong
I just was looking for a reason as to
why all these things were happening and
why people thought they were breaking up
because to me they were never gonna
break up yeah but to us it was like we
were trying to think of other things
that could have happened because we
didn't want to believe that he could
break up with me but it's like his mom
passing away would be so much worse
you're just talking about it so casually
I really apologize like I didn't I don't
think was talking to me but if you guys
like says I don't think I wasn't getting
that vibe I wasn't getting that vibe but
no and I just I hope he's okay usually I
know when people are talking to us he
just gives me Bethany vibes you know
what I mean yeah where it's like you
have this person who was like so much
going for them and like career-wise like
there's like a never-ending surplus of
great things happening for them and it
keeps getting bogged down but like
terrible tragedies in your personal life
hmm um and it's giving me Bethany vibes
and and and it's also giving me a
similar Bethany vibe
whereas I don't know if he has that many
people around him that he can depend on
and he's like building this family for
himself out of people who like aren't
you're born family it's your chosen
family and like that's what Bethany does
too because I don't think she comes from
like a really stable home life so it's
it's giving me like literally mirroring
vibes like huge careers I do think that
Jeffrey though has more friends and I
mean even family in his life than
Bethany does yeah because she has and
you could see it on the show but she got
out of the surgery like she had like
nobody at that time in her life and that
was making it so much sadder because
there's no one to celebrate
I said there's no one to consult with
you during the lows so Geoffrey gives me
like similar vibes where every time
something good happens like something
bad happens - yeah I just broke the
world record of MOCA most makeup
palettes ever sold in a certain whatever
and now his personal life is coming to
[ __ ] yeah and it's crazy because when we
watch his channel we watch a Shane show
it's like wow Jeffrey star has the best
like everybody anytime he gets on and
talks to us he's like I can go in
through a lot and he doesn't always
elaborate but it's like I can't imagine
anything like so many bad things have to
be happening to outweigh all of the
positive things that we do see you know
and it just makes some laws right what
don't we see right it just makes me sad
and this makes me sad but it didn't seem
like there was hope for reconciliation
or that either of them wanted that no
when they seem to be on good terms
Jeffrey's been snapchatting him
instagrams touring all weekend and you
put a picture up of Nate in the kitchen
with the dogs because like they they're
co-parenting there's no custody battle
but Nate wants to see his sons and
daughters which I totally understand
yeah so they seem to be getting along
really well it also makes me realize
that when Jeffrey put up the video of
the house tour that video must have been
taken a while back but by the time you
put it up they were obviously broken up
because he was saying on the video
they've been broken up for a few weeks
yeah and that's the hard part of like
being so invested in someone because
part of the reason why we refused to
believe it we're like they just put up a
video and Jeffrey pretty much films in
real time because he's always doing
things that are like pertinent like new
makeup that just came out so I never it
never occurred to me that the video
might be pre-recorded but then when he
said they'd been broken up for a while
maybe they were broken up in the video
and he was just hanging around oh I
didn't get that that's great that's like
packaging yeah yeah they're not actors
and I think Jeffrey is really upset
about say about it so and also I think
the most interesting thing is how
intertwined their lives were because
they weren't married but they were
basically like in a committed
partnership because they were together
for so long
and they have the house in Michigan that
Nate's family lives in and Jeffrey kind
of addressed how like nothing's gonna
change but like that's kind of strange
you know
yeah well maybe nothing will change for
now but down the line you know if they
both start seeing new people like that's
when things change you know or maybe
Jeffrey put the house in like Nate's
name or something like the deed maybe
like that would be very generous I'm
just really sad because I feel like
whatever was going on and I have been
watching Jeffrey's videos for a long
time and I've now go back and like watch
all the old videos so I get to see
different places in his life and it's
different places in its relationship
with Nate and it just really felt like
he was really proud of the fact that he
had like a really stable relationship
he probably people could say whatever
they wanted about him but like he had
what matters yeah and I'm just really
sad about it like I feel I feel for him
and I left him I just feel like he needs
I feel this way like how I felt about
Bethany like I feel like he really needs
like strong loyal people in his life and
like I volunteer as tribute like I feel
like I can really so much generous of
you I think you could Tim you're not
gonna pulled over you guys as a siren
yeah also um even though it's sad that
they broke up and it just like makes you
sad for him it's like it's obviously
what he wants like you know the
relationship wasn't good so being single
is ultimately better than being together
so we should I always think of a breakup
is like a good it's like a positive
change start you know what I mean so as
much as their this one is particularly
sad for us for them they're doing the
best thing for themselves we yeah we use
have to be supportive now I just I can't
imagine like Geoffrey like talking about
dating or like introducing someone else
to us because it's like your parents
like it's just it's weird like you
should be with Nate so I don't know what
where we're gonna go from a content
strategy like is he gonna include like
dating stuff in his new content I'm sure
to be so funny he's so great but I just
like it feels like I'm cheating on me it
does it really does
Wow okay well keep you posted if there's
anything new here but I just can't
believe that after a lot like from last
week where everywhere last week like
refusing to believe no to now like
morning yeah sad times we actually have
a lot of celebrity couple news for the
rest of our story so let's just get
right into it because Liam Hemsworth is
confirming a romance with Gabriella
Brooks with some PDA in Australia not
Gabby Butler no Gabrielle Brooks who's
that I don't know hear about this Liam
Hemsworth and Gabriella Brooks were
spotted kissing on the beach in Byron
Bay what about Madison brand you know
but like we knew it was over before it
even started because we never heard
about them again we ruined no it's like
it's such a big deal this is why we
can't have nice things
literally you know I'm so upset mm-hmm
they were spotted kissing in their
native Australia last week he loves an
Aussie girl I was just gonna say that as
seen in photos posted by a local
magazine on Sunday she wore a red and
white striped bikini while he sported
printed swimming trunks okay now I have
to go find the photo sorry BRB
that's kind of shocking I mean I thought
it was shocking how quickly he was like
on a date with Madison Brown oh my god
so cute they're like really kissing just
sitting on the beach check a bunch of
regular girls but this local news outlet
like anyone else post some photos
they're so excited about this I'm happy
for them I really am yeah I'm happy for
Liam of course I think he's been through
a lot romantically and I do think that
it's time for him to just like get a
really stable girlfriend in his life but
I'm really feeling sad about the loss of
potential between him and Madison Brown
it may be him ever like being an extra
on dynasty I agree you know yes people
love to do that like when you're in a
really stable relationship like they'll
break like Brad Pitt was on an episode
of friends you know anything like that
yeah so like we could have gotten Liam
Hemsworth on an episode of dynasty and
that's really what the show needs yeah
you know totally damn well I really at
the end of the day want happiness for
him because he really seems like he
deserves it even though again we have no
clue what goes on behind closed doors
and no one will give us any [ __ ]
answers oh yeah matter we literally
spend so much time we built a [ __ ]
brand we built a studio around like
talking about other people and they
won't even get open the window like way
to heaven and it's like they show us
everything that they want to show us but
the one time like we actually are
interested in with just like a little
bit of clarity on a certain situation we
get nothing
squat also is it a story did we talk
about a hailey Bieber running into
Selena Gomez no because I'm so done with
these people I can't even tell you I'm
really dumb asleep like and I just don't
understand okay
like I don't even I just slid ago my
head like an album release party her
album came out rare I haven't really
heard anything about it other than the
fact that snitch says it's pretty good
my thought snitch said she was trying
like switch was trying to enjoy it she
found two songs that were okay I
actually listen to it this morning
because um I wanted if they came up I
just wanted to like share my thoughts I
only got through half of it and it's
just very like Selena Gomez it plays on
the radio enough times maybe I'll get
into it but to me it just sounds like it
like a series of notes put together well
what had happened was she was out
celebrating at a restaurant had like a
little album release party and Haley
Bieber went to dinner with Madison beer
which is so funny and they happened to
be at the same restaurant and people
thought that like Haley was ambushing
Selena now I do feel like that's weird
it's weird and I do feel like Haley
Bieber I love her and I actually really
/ in Justin and I'm happy that he ended
up with her not Selena but I do think
there's an element of like weirdness
with her because I always find myself
reporting news about her and Selena
Gomez being like link she just keeps
stepping in it and I feel like he was
liking random pictures from Selena Gomez
fan accounts like she's just like so
strange and I don't you know what
restaurant the party was that no because
if it was out like Nobu Malibu okay
maybe like that really is a pop in place
and everyone could wind up there but if
it was just that like some random diner
yeah I do want to know what restaurant
it was because I think that would change
things but also apparently Madison beers
friends with Selena Gomez so like
wouldn't Madison beer know where the
after card wait so Selena Gomez and that
assembiy are both commented on like a
fan account that was like reporting the
story and Selena was like there was
absolutely no blood I love Madison so
much like Selena said it was fine and
Madison said it was fine but it just
feels like this easily could have been
avoided easily could have been avoided
and it's just it's nonsense and I'm so
tired of talking about it especially
when it's like they'll like do something
that seems like it might be drama yeah
why do you think there's drama and it's
like taking jabs been ten years so you
still shocked that Justin Haley still
commenting on photos you guys are being
shady and thirsty and like we're just
talking about it and it's our fault no
but that's the thing we're not even
talking about it because I'm not talking
about it no but I do just want to I
wanted to report on it that I'm Tina Ali
but I definitely think she's a little
weird yeah no this was like one step too
far I totally agree this isn't final
story a little more celeb couple news um
Gigi and Zayn spotted back together in
New York you know what in the words of
pretty Spears toxic oh my god in the
words of Britney Spears oops
I just what are you I don't know like
they're they're just meant for each
other
they're things yes I really do like no
matter where they go they always come
back to each other and I actually think
they're cute and they look really good
together like their faces are meant to
be together um I just there's something
that gives me like bad vibes about this
relationship like yeah just hotness like
blind items in probably those that
you've read and heard um but just if I'm
gonna be like one of those people who
just looks at a tabloid at a tabloid and
takes it at face value
I think Gigi and Zane are ODP and I
think that they should stop bringing
other people into this like Tyler see
and
like they want to move on serving people
I'm not moving on Joe Jonas right I just
I I love Gigi and I have recently
restained her like my relationship with
her it's kind of toxic as well like I
was her number one fan and I feel like I
made her famous just by like literally
being obsessed with her like telling
everyone about her on the Real
Housewives like nobody even knew she was
she was just a lot of daughter doing
some guest campaigns and then I really
feel like I brought her into the 21st
century but like obviously it didn't I
just and then I then I got like mad at
her for being so famous and like losing
everything about you and losing that
accessibility like I had to her so then
I like kind of became over her and like
kind of became like a hater
and now I'm back to like loving her
because like she just wasn't respected
Taylor Swift and like I just love that
about her um and I love her dating life
I do think it's so interesting and it's
a really like important element in her
career whether like that's misogynistic
or not like it is like who she dates is
super interesting and like I feel like
who she dates really reflects how I feel
about her like I absolutely loved her
when she was dating Joe Jonas because I
just thought that was like such a good
choice and I was like good for you like
he's not the obvious choice because he
wasn't the biggest star in the world
back then he was more low-key and I just
like loved that choice for her and then
she just went directly to Zayn and I
just thought that was like so obvious
you know and I just thought like man but
now they just like keep like finding
their way back to each other and I do
think that they're cute I just jump
think I just don't know if it's the best
thing for her I think it's the best
thing for her because it's the heart
what's in the words of Selena Gomez the
heart wants what it wants
yeah and she had to lose you to love me
yeah and look at her now Wow very well
done yeah no I just think that they love
each other so much and they need to find
a way to make it work in the right way
to take it all the way because they just
keep coming back to each other and I
think that this is it for them and I
just don't know how they couldn't make
it work because Zayn doesn't work so
like Gigi is super busy like she's the
biggest supermodel in the world I'm
running a brand like killing it um and I
could understand how it would be
difficult to date her if you two have a
lot going on but Jane Malik as far as I
know doesn't have much going on so I
just feel like you should really travel
with Gigi she I feel like she's very
stable like she has really good like
work-life balance yeah I feel like she
goes to bed early
she's not like a crazy party girl no but
she also has a good time and she's a
good group of friends like I feel like
he she's really good for him yes and
he's good for her because she loves him
yes that's that's how I feel also even
if he is busy or gets busy or maybe he's
busy and like we don't know about it you
know jon favreau today he's so busy
um you know Joe Jonas and sophie Turner
are able to make it work
you're able to make it work as well yeah
I I no longer subscribe to the notion of
scheduling conflicts because here they
said about Lady Gaga and Taylor Kinney
and did you see how New Year she was
spotted with the mystery man kissing him
and it looked like Taylor Kinney I don't
think that it was but I just want to say
him kept my hopes
I know it looked like him and I like
forever will hold out hope like
obviously I was upset when she like
we're about for engagement from Chris
and Karina but then I wasn't that upset
because I just meant it she's one step
closer to getting back together with
Taylor kidding
her once you love in this entire world
right and I mean like I had been able to
put them out of my mind for a while and
just like focus on other things
no they forgot her heart-shaped
engagement ring like I'm Thank You
Touche and just like you bring this back
to the surface sorry I
you don't understand the progress I the
work I've done on myself I'm sorry and I
honestly didn't even chip her and
Bradley Cooper because I knew that
Taylor Kinney was the one true love for
and I'm glad that she and Bradley Cooper
didn't work out because that would have
just brought her further away from
coming back to the one true love Taylor
Kinney
what about Lady Gaga I'm Brad Pitt Oh
honestly I feel like he really is and I
would say I don't know anything about
him or ever met him but I feel like he's
looking for like a really simple girl
and Lady Gaga is many things but she's
not simple I don't know he's looking for
a simple girl but I agree that like I
wouldn't necessarily pair the two but um
don't worry you're not getting pulled
over and whisk up our mates because
imagine if you are getting pulled over
like they're simultaneous sirens so much
drama so much drama it's just like I'm
sympathetic to the cause of like
whatever they're running to be like can
you hurry the [ __ ] up I'm like recording
a podcast here sir no I mean service is
just like living in New York and I'm
telling you guys I'm at my wit's end
like with living in New York with with
living in New York right now it's all of
it I don't know I really like need to
get out a map and and start planning and
plotting because I'm making moves do it
are you going you already just asked me
that oh did you say where you're going
no but I'm I I'm just trying to talk
over the [ __ ] siren why don't
we just meet ourselves and sit here and
then kind of have the podcast community
Leslie
50 minutes animal cut okay we're back
and that vow of silence was brought to
you by fabletics fabletics Creed's
clothing that's made to inspire physical
activity in any type of setting
moreover fabletics always aims to create
fashionable on-trend workout clothing at
an exceptional price point their mantra
is live your passion every day go online
to fabletics take a quick 60 second
style pop quiz for personalized outfit
recommendations shut from thousands of
styles curated just for you you can
check out as a guest or become a VIP but
there's tons of perks if you want to
become a VIP member you can get up to up
to 50% off a regular prices free
shipping and additional perks right now
you can get to leggings for only $24
it's an almost $100 value but if you use
a VIP and use our special link you can
get two leggings for only $24 so that's
fabletics comm slash toast and the code
is toast if you want to get two leggings
for only $24.99 Inc it's really
comfortable and makes people think I
like live this like really tan say I'm
at like elevated life when we all know
that I don't
in fabletics is your one-stop shop for
affordable athletic where they have yoga
running gym wear sports bras shoes
accessories and more Margaux is obsessed
with their sports bra and as a big
titted woman I can attest to the fact
that they work at the big-titted woman I
love their sports size I have one in my
purse because I'm gonna put it on later
today get to leggings for $24 which is
almost half the price of a Lululemon
sports bra get an entire outfit for half
the price of most traditional retailers
- the link that we have for you guys is
fabletics dot-com slash toast the code
is toast make sure to go to fabletics
calm and use the code toast to get two
pairs of leggings for just $24 and $100
value that we are getting for you for a
mere twenty four dollars that's like
three coffees sign-on looks snatched
while you get snatched yeah about that
okay know what shariq I have a text from
the snacks are telling me that the
restaurant was Craig's Oh
so you know what Haley I'm gonna give
this one back yeah every something like
Nobu or Craig yeah every celebrity in
there likes her if you go to Craig's
like at any time of day there's a huge
celebrity it really is possible that the
two of them just decided to go to
Craig's on a Saturday
neutral ground yeah it is it's but I
can't believe that hasn't happened
before
yeah okay okay switch thank you for the
update thank you this snatchler let's
talk about cheer which is a series like
I just watched on Netflix I opened my
computer while waiting for my flight to
Kansas City and it was just there and I
clicked it I didn't know it's gonna
become like a worldwide phenomenon and
I'm so glad I got in on it early that
never happens for me like I always hear
about things later yeah I didn't like
reluctantly watch them but my god was a
show made for us or what made for us
like we are a couple of girls who just
respect the hell out of cheerleaders and
growing up like I think we wish we just
like we're in so ground and rotund
because like we would have been
cheerleaders anybody tried to start a
cheerleading squad but we had to wear
skirts like below our knees and I'm
sorry but that's just not gonna happen
it's like in order to be a good
cheerleader like you have to dress
provocatively yeah you can't have a
dress code and be a cheerleader be like
the cheerleaders in Greece like in the
50s like when they showed those old
Clint yes yeah that was that um what it
made me realized was that I think bring
it on did an amazing job of capturing
Daytona Oh a hundred percent I think it
made me realize so many things and it
really is a shame for these cheerleaders
that cheer as an industry isn't
respected enough to have some sort of
competitive it competitive sport after
college yeah it was really interesting
how like the benchmark and like the peak
that you can get even as the best
cheerleader Gabby Butler is collegiate
and that's why they go to junior college
like Navarro for two years and then
regular college because then that's six
years like they're they're just like
putting so much time and energy into
like perfecting their bodies and letting
these routines all to just like get a
job in marketing afterwards right that
is just I can't I can't accept that I
was trying to think of good jobs for
cheerleaders and they do think that some
of them maybe not nabarro cheer girls
and guys because they're so talented but
a lot of them like why not do NFL NBA
cheerleading yeah even though that's
more dancing it is but also you know the
bring on series is still in effect
I just watched cheer smack and like why
isn't Gabby Butler in the movie and by
the way the movie is about cheer
liberties and I thought they were making
that up sort of I didn't realize that
there really weathers whole shared world
and the movie is about Gabby Butler like
a girl who's just like lost her edge Oh
Gabby by the way I've so many favorite
characters and really everyone is a
favorite and they show their do that
everyone's favorite Lexi oh I didn't
like she's so talented they show
everyone's journey enough for you to
come to to love them and I think Jerry
is just the best example of
I agree that I've ever seen in my life
I'd like I just kept being so impressed
with him like from a personality
standpoint like when he didn't make Matt
he didn't get upset he stood like that's
the type of person like your teacher
tells you to be like you never are like
pretend but like you really are low-key
mad that you're not on that but he was
genuinely so happy for everyone that was
on that his by the way when they were
showing how like you're supposed to like
talk to each other during the routine
and how Jerry is so funny like his voice
is so nasally yeah I didn't stop doing
that even when he didn't make Matt and
I'm so glad that he obviously did make
Matt um because I just support him so
much but I felt so bad for him cuz he's
not a tumbler and he's not a center like
he's just a center Center but yeah I
just felt like he is definitely the type
of person like we should all try and be
in 2020 like so supportive so nice so
funny and I love that he ended up going
to college at the University of
Louisville and got there based on his
grade but according to Instagram he's
back at Navarro that's yeah oh this yes
I mean sure he's playing on the Wildcats
no snitch and I we're doing deep dives
and Amir facetiming last night because I
wish like the whole time during the
movie I was just like what are these
people gonna do after I was really
curious but I didn't want to spoil it
for myself and Jerry is back at Navarro
so is Morgan who by the way but Morgan
wouldn't was a first-year student oh she
wasn't she was two years and how can you
go back
um I guess she maybe had like more
credits that she could do
oh yeah it says 2 days ago Jerry Harris
back and better than ever at Navarro
yeah a lot of them are back at Navarro
and I said that part is making me sad
especially because they worked so hard
and they got they got what they what
they worked hard for like they spoiler
alert if you have but also if you
haven't seen it why are you listening
but um they won Daytona yeah but and but
also like I don't think that they should
go back to Navarro and do it all again
like their bodies are breaking yeah it's
not meant to be done more for more than
two years yeah but I just want to talk
more about some of the characters I want
to talk about Gabi Butler because I felt
so terribly for her I really really
liked her I thought she was a really
sweet and like strong stoic person to
young person or such a young person her
parents put so much [ __ ] pressure on
heard they're literally like parents out
of a movie yes it was so crazy when they
were fighting on the couch in the
beginning I was like oh that's kind of
cute and then I would know and then when
they were like dealing with the laundry
and everything in micromanaging her and
like making her do these shoots at until
3:00 a.m. in
wondering why she can't fly the next day
it's like no there's nothing wrong with
Gabby Butler as a cheerleader other than
the fact that she spiked him tired
she's a maybe if she slept one night
like she's an incredible cheerleader
yeah and the the scene where Navarro's
over and they're like figuring out what
to do when he's like calling all these
gyms trying to like set up a pyramid
scheme like everyone has to pay $100 if
they're raised like it was just so sad
because like you thought like she
reached his goal and like she could
finally take a break for a minute no
they're sending her on a tour
no and I'm so glad that this series has
come out because now they're all getting
a live Instagram followers and that'll
help them you know that really becomes a
job for a model like she's probably at
almost 800 K now which is great she can
sell the bikinis and whatnot but I just
I felt like she was really nice it was
just like everyone not even her parents
like everyone and her family just like
relying off of her yeah and it's like
her her complaining that Gabby doesn't
post it up in the bikinis like leave her
alone she's busy traveling around the
world being the face of rebel I know and
like going to cheer for other teams at
the highest level they know and he can't
like flying everywhere doing the [ __ ]
moaning routines in two days and : then
the mom when someone was like Oh who's
your daughter and the mom was like oh
that one she's like Gabby Butler and the
mom was like yeah she's like what she's
a normal girl she is a normal actually
so normal it's like yes she is you're
making her into a monster like the mom
was so out of control the mom was so out
of control and Gabby was the one who I
felt like everyone else was really like
having the best time of their life yeah
Navaro and Gabby was just like still
like it was almost like this is the
worst time of her life just trucking
through it like it wasn't a moment where
she could stop and stand in the ocean
and like look around and how much he
accomplished it she was probably fly for
another team she was on the plane
already yeah I just I I feel really bad
leave her and her parents I need to calm
down and I think she was she took so
much and yes she like basically never
answered her parents and didn't respond
when they said I love you but she also
didn't lash out at them and I respect
that totally I didn't think she was
being a bad kid at all like I thought
you not only handling herself well like
I don't know how she she must just tune
out her mom her mom is so annoying I
can't and like I just think there aren't
a lot of opera there aren't a lot of
things to do I understand her dad like
trying to make fetch happen I'd like
make the most of the moment because it's
bleeding like a cheerleading as a young
person sport like I get that but my god
but I think there's just other things
that they could that they could do I
don't know call me crazy no I agree
so I just really like turned I'd like to
how much she like was friends with
cherry like I just love to the
friendships Morgan was a PG job and her
backstory was literally devastating or
breaking like leaving them in the
trailer and then you find out a few
episodes later that the brother left the
trailer to yeah and she was completely
living alone like as a high schooler
yeah and then you also find out that the
dad is still in their lives and they
just like all look back on it and it's
blurry confusion yeah even the
grandparents like who were so precious
so precious I'm just I was so happy for
Morgan like she worked so hard like hard
work pays off yeah and then she became
the top girl right in the beginning I
was feeling like a little annoyed with
Monica because she basically what she
had said was that was Morgan the best
cheerleader no but she has the look so
it's like she's getting to this
prestigious spot just because she's like
cute and pretty and has the physique
that Monica thinks but then towards the
end I really felt like she earned her
spot on the team and it wasn't just
because she was like super cute yeah she
had a little look and potential I don't
think Monica just takes anyone who's Joe
then Jerry's backstory like I'm
literally with sobbing sobbing I was sad
in the city and I was just like on my
laptop in the greenroom like it
sterically crying because I just
couldn't get the vibe like where they
were going like what happened to the mom
did she disappeared like yeah because
they were making it's he's cheer mom the
one who lives in a huge house in
Illinois was like his mom was a class
all her own and then enough she meant
that as a negative thing or a positive
thing is it again he said yes so I
didn't know if they were gonna say like
she abandoned Jerry or like she was
amazing and she's an angel and like
every time they brought up his mom like
Jeremy I think yeah I can't even talk
about her Enochs I'm like so upset like
and he never once broke down like how
how I don't know like he is a better
human than all of us and he needs to be
come bless you a cheer coach like that
has his destiny so I'm I've been
following them an instrument in his bio
says he's an NCAA like spirit leader or
something and I see him that was like
taking pictures all these like younger
squad at Daytona they had a girl in NCH
hair leader who was like cheering with
the trophy before it was announced like
that needs to be Jerry yeah he's just so
amazing and like when they were showing
like his journey through cheerleading
and how like he been cheering for a
young age and like the club's that he
would share and like everybody loved
Jerry and they were showing like all
these pictures and he's just just like
the cutest person ever it was so I was
literally hysterically crying but also
up like got my period yesterday so maybe
I was just like I don't know if I would
have cried otherwise
like I [ __ ] love him yeah and I
thought it was really interesting also
like the socioeconomic backgrounds of a
lot of the people and how you realize
like like half these kids came from a
traditional chair which is expensive
like you have to be of a certain
background to like pay for chair every
weekend those clubs and the all-star
it's expensive like it and to get there
the traditional way is like you have to
be well-off and then most of them really
came from like that like bad backgrounds
had just made their way there and we're
scrappy and that's my ladarius was
getting so angry with that girl like she
wasn't doing anything wrong but he was
just like [ __ ] like you've had
everything handed she like you just got
cheer like your parents paid your way
and like just lend lend the plane like
land the basket or whatever and he was
wrong and that and he was like I'm
starting to I couldn't decide whether
how I felt about ladarius I was really
getting pissed off at certain points
especially when he was throwing girls in
the air and then like walking away and
I'm that girl is already like a scared
cheerleader right it's only got rights
got injured at weed and also I
understand being a scare to earlier
flying through the air and you just
watched a girl fall in breaker I'm
completely understand my god when that
girl broke her arm um where was
everybody Monica was so hell-bent the
whole season I'm like figuring out who
was wrong in what situation because
blaming it's we plays they never figured
out who was wrong where she literally
fell into her basket and there was no
basket you know everyone just left and
then she literally was just tubing the
motions and I saw that there was nobody
there and oh my god that was so crazy so
I understood why the girl Ali or Alex or
whatever her name was
was scared and also ladarius like when
you watch him in practice he wasn't
always he's just like pretty flip it was
both of it so like you're already scared
in your and someone is catching you who
doesn't even really care to catch it
it's just like tossing you it was they
were both wrong because this stunt
wasn't landing for a reason and it
wasn't just Ali like it was both of them
and he was really getting me know and I
was like starting not to like him and
then the whole thing with the bad girls
club was like making me love him and
like how much they loved the bad girls
club and how much I liked it to find
their friendship was so funny and then
also hearing about his background I'm
like everyone is family like when he
said he was bullied I was like believed
by people in his family for being fruity
like it was just that was really
heartbreak and then he was molested by
one of the people in the daycare center
like I just I I totally got why he was
acting out like he and it took a silly
excuse like he's acting out because he's
angry like how did he still just a kid
you know it's not like you know I'm real
housewives and he will blame their cast
like he's only 18
yeah we're 20 years old and he's also an
incredible cheerleader like oh my oh man
they were showing him the first time the
sideline oh my god he is like an amazing
cheerleader because he has so much cheer
in him but the like the stunting the
tumbling insanity in Saturday um also
Lexi I didn't like her like really at
all the entire time I thought she was um
like when it was just like and I know
you can't compare people's backgrounds
but like from hearing what like what a
lot of the people had been through and
then Lexi kind of just coming in and
saying her parents divorce like made her
spiral and like she went through a bad
phase like I just didn't really feel bad
for her and I know that's bad because
everyone's journey is their own but it's
like just comparing it to Morgan who was
left in a trailer ladarius who tried to
commit suicide like I just I couldn't
deal for Lexi um I just thought she was
kind of like bratty and then she was
like really not getting into the spirit
with anyone like she was just not the
whole time I was like who Shanon with
the group job and it was like there was
a reason you were invited like she just
was like kind of thought she was like
better than everyone um and talent-wise
she was amazing and it was never a
question whether or not she was gonna be
on that but there's more to being a part
of the team than just being a
cheerleader like you have to be a good
team member but by the end she she came
together with everyone well but and then
she didn't because she got kicked off
the team right and she was making bad
decisions at a rave with her enormous
babe yeah well she was always to
sleeping the whole season yeah and I
think that's important to know like
apparently you can be an incredible
family an athlete at MAPE this huge
[ __ ] baby it was literally the size
of educator like it was just it was just
so weird and it was an important detail
that they kept like just making sure we
saw yeah and then she's like at a rave
while everyone's having their lives
together like Jerry having a full
scholarship to the University of
Louisville which I knew had a really
prestigious um
cheerleading program because in glee
Santana went and it was like a really
big deal oh that's exciting
yeah apparently he doesn't go well I
need to like double check that cuz I'm
like really upset if that's true
I know because he got a scholarship like
why wouldn't he go I don't know and I've
been looking at all of their instagrams
like they started like and I keep
checking in like 30k now that 80 the
Gabby obviously started with 500 but
Morgan is not like a hundred like I just
more than that like 200 I'm good I hope
they all just become influencers yeah
and I have you followed any of them yet
just Jeremiah Harris I haven't followed
any of them but I literally check them
all the time that's why she just follow
I've been following Gabby and Morgan
she's followed the whole creo yeah I
picked really good kids kids and I
thought it was cool how Monica was
involved and she was like you should
Mike ladarius because you've never seen
anyone like him um and then Monica who's
just the hero amongst heroes and I loved
how she was like uh yeah it's a very
conservative town but like if anyone
comes from my boys like I even talked to
my master about it I'm just I don't
understand it I just love Ted she really
liked was an LGBTQ queen and she just
seems like it was like a kind of cliche
how it's like you know this ragtag group
of kids like Monica believes in that but
it really is like a ragtag group of kids
and Monica really does believe in them
yeah she works them so hard
42 full outs like I couldn't oh my god
putting it but it all paid off
yeah because they went oh but then wait
okay I have a thought and I saw someone
tweeted this at me and I actually
thought the same thing too like were
there oh and I don't want to diminish
their accomplishments but were there
only two teams in their division because
they were automatically in the top tier
which they wouldn't they would have made
a big deal like they just said like they
were just there with Trinity Valley no
but like I don't know it's like in bring
it on there were so many teams but on
the mat at the end like there was only
three oh yeah of course but and they
only talked about they're not going to
show they also talked about Trinity
Valley Trinity Valley was the only one
on the mat with them so worst case
scenario they could've come in a second
like no no there was definitely like
okay waters need to know that for sure
because if they went to all this just to
not come in second like no I think there
is totally more but the top two stand on
the mat and yeah get it out but I just
feel like they would have included them
becoming top - no I because the whole
time is them they never were worried
about coming in third but maybe because
there was only two teams right no no
where's more at no no and it's a whole
thing
it's up to Trinity Valley I thought we
were gonna now like get to know these
kids and I really wasn't in the mood no
I was not interesting two episodes to
get here ya know moving forwards but I
do hope that this becomes like a series
where maybe at Navarro every year with
like different kids or like different
schools
I just thought no I want a thousand Gabi
Morgan uh Jerry do you you want to leave
Navarro if they're out of Navarro
I know it depends where they go right
well that was a thing like Navarro being
such a great program only being a
two-year school that kind of sucks yeah
oh and also how come like
some like Harvard doesn't recruit Monica
and just have the best chair team in the
country because like no one cares no
right that's what it boils down to no
one [ __ ] cares like you don't get
boosters it's not on ESPN anymore that
was crazy that hold varsity chill my god
so crazy Scientology I need a patriot
wait also the best part the best person
is miss patty oh yeah when she's talking
about how great Monica is and she's like
and I don't know if you were filming but
that's how lucky she was so cute and
like it was just really giving me like a
Friday Night Lights like home town like
it was oh yeah Monica's Coach Taylor
yeah and like so and then when they were
all tapping the thing out of the locker
room like that's what they used to do
clear eyes full hearts like I just it
was such a good series like linear a
series nobody asked for but we needed so
bad it so desperately and the
cheerleaders of America needed it
because they are some of the most
talented athletes in in the country and
they don't get the respect that they
deserve and they don't get multi-million
dollar contracts you know just to ride
the bench so right with Nike right
we need guy but also like with the NFL
we need Gabby Barry to be like the face
of women's Nike or something yeah she oh
my god totally that's what we need like
beyond rebel athletic I hope like of all
this like that's what comes like she
could be the next like Jen Selter like
like thirsty Instagram girl a hundred
percent that's what I want for her yeah
I really want the best for her I really
do it was such I was so upset when I was
over six episodes are you kidding me no
it was the perfect amount no no no cuz
if we had to stretch longer the time
that we're waiting for Daytona like you
wouldn't have enjoyed it just seeing
them fall more and more like Daytona was
couldn't didn't come soon enough
yeah yeah at some point it was just like
all right do they win or do they lose
right yeah the routine was brilliant
yeah and it's interesting to see how
every team comes together because there
are so many elements like tumbling
baskets like and they do it all in parts
and then when they do it together for
the first time it's like literally
putting like 600 puzzle pieces together
yeah really interesting while you're out
of breath right oh my god and it's only
two minutes in 15 seconds and they
literally can't breathe afterwards yeah
like I could never be a cheerleader I
can't breathe like after a flight of
stairs
yeah no it was it was crazy stuff and
I'm really grateful to Netflix and you
tomorrow cheer squad
it was the series that nobody asked for
it but that we all desperately needed
desperately and like I just have so much
respect for them so yeah and I hope that
this actually makes the Daytona go back
to ESPN now that there will definitely
be more interest I'm watching um I want
to watch yeah and now I've to follow
Gerry on Instagram just to find out like
when NCAA is because like who knows I
think it's in April I was like what I
went back together Instagram I couldn't
believe that varsity cheer didn't let
them film yeah it said we came all this
way just to like watch it on an iPhone
but they did a really good job of making
their own behind the scenes yeah in the
corner somewhere in the front yeah but
it's like they couldn't even get the
footage from no they probably would have
had to pay for it they should have
Netflix big budget no but I'm sure
varsity was gonna charge Netflix big
budget I just hope that like all these
kids who were in the documentary like
made some money from it
oh I don't think so but I think the
opportunities will coming right maybe if
there's a second season maybe they'll
like renegotiate get a talent agent I
don't know if I want a second season
because the the last half of the last
episode when it was post Daytona I found
to be the most boring me too and it took
me like double the amount of time to go
through because I was just checking
their Instagram except the part about
Lexie but that was disappointing kind of
substances did you I need to know like
was it you know heroin or was it weed it
wasn't we'd know it was only like it
probably wasn't heroin probably like
cocaine probably but who knows we're
just making that maybe a little jingle
jangle hi cutie patootie Theo has been
here today you probably didn't know
because he was being such a good
[ __ ] more because that's my son
okay that's my man
that's my nephew don't come for him come
here anyways that's our show for you
today I wonder if there was anything
else that we wanted to talk about oh I
would did one talk about shark tank very
strange episode and I loved weight by
the way in their pre-show chat they said
shark big hoo-ha yeah that's for mo that
was also part of their music yes in this
year it was like I hear the beginning of
the cheer song in my head like oh dogs
yeah who's boo dude it was like
literally like a rave yeah Lexie must
been having such a great time anyway
that's all we happen to you today I want
to talk about our team because I right
off the bat they came in with a kid and
a horse she got a deal Damon and Lauri
coming together good for a stock company
yet he can't going on any other socks
because of Bombay's apparently was it a
good idea it's a sock that has a little
slit so you could put your phone in it
what my phone is as big as my foot
no wait like the socks go up to your
cabin and you just like side here who
needs a phone sock Claudia hey by the
way so you have to not be wearing pants
with pockets a jacket a purse and they
did an update on the squatty potty oh
and the best invention ever we've sold
over 4 million squatty potty's the woman
who started it is now like retiring she
sold half the company for eight figures
oh so now she just bought like she made
like a huge retirement house blah blah
blah and she's an older woman and at
first nak was like to me he's like okay
or not eight just look how successful
she is I was like no when she told her
story
Lori's like all the Sharks were just
like laughing at her when they first saw
it but Lori took it seriously and why
were they laughing because they're eight
just a squatty potty is literally the
most amazing invention ever like I am
responsible for one of those four
million sales and it has changed my
digestive system like I just I can't
recommend it enough
and I went to a party like a while ago
and I went into the bathroom who's that
someone's apartment they did squatty
potty and it's like pretty squatty potty
100% it was really like it's on ice come
on Linc
Wow the show has been going on for a
really long time anymore I was it's
11:45
we must go you guys
oh yeah we did we have work to do but
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go live money running to
my god the NC arms were very busy
what's NC when they were when they would
go to math they'd be like Navarro
College UNC Oh
oh my god Sadie new millennium morning
show will be go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up leave a
comment thanks so much I'm also
available as a podcast which you know if
you listening to us as a podcast we're
available anywhere pretty much anywhere
podcasts we found so that's about if I
actually sit your public with you I have
radio casts box all the plate says so
make sure to subscribe to us wherever
you listen to podcast and leave a
five-star review about our beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys so much have an amazing game you'll
see you tomorrow on Tuesday bye bye